could an f-22 raptor take on a death
glider
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
move your channel
[Music]
so
as all good discussions should begin
i was in the public and we were talking
about death gliders and the f302 now the
f302 we've seen it repeatedly in
stargate absolutely batter the death
glider they can take them one-on-one and
have been very successful
why can't any conventional aircraft do
that why couldn't f-22 do that
and initially i went
don't be stupid
so let's compare the two let's compare
the f 22
to the gold death glider first of all
the death glider has a maximum speed
within an atmosphere of about 1200 kph
this is actually equivalent to the
raptors maximum speed actually their
after can go a little quicker even
though it does have a supercruise
capability where it can actually stay at
supersonic flight for much longer than
other conventional aircraft could dream
of
the f-22 obviously has a far more
limited range than the death glider the
death glider powered by liquid macular
can pretty much have unlimited range
first score
kind of a draw within an atmosphere
these aircraft are roughly the same
speed and have probably similar climb
rates
according to several sources the f302
that we know can take on and go toe
with a death glider
has a similar capability for
maneuverability point of view as the
f-22 raptor but we know from the battle
over antarctica that there was a
dogfight between f302s and death gliders
and that they seem to be roughly
comparable so i think it's safe to
assume
that the f-22 raptor could
roughly
go toe-to-toe with the death glider and
be roughly as maneuverable so again it's
kind of a draw
the f-22 has thrust vectoring capability
so that really makes it one of the most
maneuverable large aircraft in
the military right now now the death
glider and the f302 in fact have
inertial dampening systems it doesn't
basically exert as many g's onto the
pilot
one way of thinking about this is that
the f302 might be as maneuverable as the
raptor
it feels like a raptor to fly but it
actually feels like you're on a large
passenger jet when you're actually
flying it there isn't the g-forces that
the f-22 raptor pilot would have to put
up with so let's think about weapon
systems
the f-22 raptor carries um an arsenal of
up to eight missiles normally six aim
120s and two signed wider missiles
now this is really important because the
aim 120 missile is what they call an
over horizon weapon system it has a
range of around 160 kilometers and it
can do mach 4.
so this is a very clever weapon system
and and really important because that is
one of the main reasons why the f302 was
so capable versus the death glider
because it uses missiles the missiles
have a far greater range than the staff
cannons that the
death glider uses so in the same way
that the f302 uses its missiles against
a death glider so would the f-22
the f-22 raptor would fire its
radar-guided missiles at very long range
and then turn around and leg it
in a one-on-one fight between an f-22
and a death glider i don't think the
death glider would even get within 100
miles of the raptor but how about if
they got into a close-up combat
situation
in that case i believe actually the
death glider would be more maneuverable
than the raptor also the raptor would
only have its forward-facing cannon it
wouldn't have the firepower to take on
the
death glider in an actual straight-up
fight in that way the staff cannons
don't run out of ammunition they can
keep firing they obviously are a
devastating weapon system and as soon as
the death guide gets close enough to hit
them that they would have no chance it's
actually though not clear what missile
system the f302 uses they say fox 2
during the battle of antarctica you
actually hear the pilot say that now
that normally means a heat-seeking
missile system
fox 3 would be a radar-guided missile
system but
you generally don't use radar-guided
missile systems in close combat like
there was at the antarctica you would
use heat-seeking missiles
so let's break it down the f-22 can
match speed at least for short periods
of time they have to introduce can
possibly match maneuverability and the
f-22 has the advantage of a long-range
missile system that could hit the death
glider before they even got close
so
in a one-on-one situation
assuming the radar missile systems can
lock on and that they go basically don't
come up with a
way of getting around that or a way of
blocking that
the f-22 raptor would be more than
capable of taking on a death glider and
the death glider would not even see the
enemy coming
but in a close-up dog fight
i wouldn't want to be a border raptor
in a close-up dogfight the death glider
has a better capability with short-range
weapon systems and they have unlimited
firepower
if you had a dogfight with squadrons
against squadrons
basically several death fighters against
several raptors
if they have the capability of taking
the death gliders out of distance then
this would be a very very short battle
but if they had to get in close and fire
up close
the f-302 has rail guns that could give
it some teeth
the f-22 raptor doesn't
it would have absolutely no chance
except for its two sidewinder missiles
and once it ran out of ammunition once
it ran out of those missiles it would be
a duck shoot for the death gliders
i think the capability of the f302
basically in a dog fight isn't that
dissimilar to the capabilities of the
f-22 raptor but the main reason why the
f-302 is so able to take on a death
glider is because the missiles and the
missiles are exactly the same as the
missiles you would get aboard the f-22
raptor so for that reason and that
reason alone yes the f-22 raptor could
take on a death glider as long as the
death glider isn't allowed to get too
close
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification share the video wherever
the hell you like and really start the
debate go over onto facebook there's a
link in the description also you can
join the channel and help me produce
more material
every i try to get videos out every week
on all these different subjects also
leave a comment is there anything else
you would like me to discuss on one of
these videos
thanks guys please stay safe and i'll
see you next time
[Music]